Take a simple needle arrangement
and racking for a beautiful
open work lace-like fabric.
The needles out of work
create the open spaces
With this needle arrangement set
your ribber to H5 and knit two rows
swing to H3 knit to rows and repeat.
Now here's a tip, since we're
racking every other row, if
you need to stop knitting end
with the carriage on the left.
That way you won't forget
if you've racked or not.
When you come back, you'll knit to
the right and it'll be time to rack.
I removed my ribber for this sample.
And because I was in a hurry, this is just
a swatch, I cast on with full needle rib,
then dropped the stitches and put needles
in and out of work for the pattern.
Then continued knitting.
The oops, on the right.
If I had used a 7 or a wire weight hanger,
this could have prevented the mess.
I hope you'll try this technique.
Different needle arrangements,
different racking sequences will create
completely different lace like fabrics.